oh don't you love the new graphics we're
fancy here at eight news now welcome
back everybody it's 6 39
time for mondays with monica ladies if
you have a second and guys too but
ladies mostly
we're getting ready for a go red for
women it happens on february 5th but i
wanted to get a jump on it because it's
all about raising awareness about heart
disease in women
and here to talk more about that is
cardiologist dr karthik narala
thank you so much for joining us how you
doing doc
i'm doing great thank you for having me
this morning absolutely okay let's get
right into it because
you know in the tease i i said you know
it's all about heart disease where we
are versus where we need to be
give us the overall picture of where we
are with heart disease when it comes to
women
well monica um i think um a lot of
people don't know is that the
cardiovascular disease is the number one
killer in women
actually um it's anywhere between 20
to 33 of women depending on what you
read uh but overall it's still the
number one
um in an entire year approximately 300
000 women die
each year of heart disease um and
you know it's been a lot of improvement
in how we deal with heart disease but
you know that we saw
we still have a long way to go actually
and um
heart disease i think is really under
diagnosed because
there's a lot of myths in how people
perceive
heart disease and you know they think
it's for old people which is not true
um heart disease and plaque can start
building up as
early as your 20s um and then
and then other people think i don't have
any symptoms so i'm fine
um and and that's not true as well
because you know you classically see
the guy that clutches the chest and
falls and
that's going to be your heart disease
however there's a lot of
different symptoms that can happen you
know you can have people that have
shortness of breath yeah they just feel
out of shape i'm getting older
or they have back pain jaw pain neck
pain and these are all different ways
that it can present so these are kind of
uh
symptoms that need to be understood
better so that people can
be more aware and see their doctor
sooner absolutely doc let me get into
the weeds here because
covet 19 has shut down and i'll be
honest with you i missed a lot of
appointments early on
and in all transparency ladies and
gentlemen dr karthik narala
his dad is my heart doctor i started
going to him when i turned
40 but um you know heart disease in the
minority communities the black and brown
communities it's gotten out of control
and with covid
a lot of people have said you know
they're not going to the doctor nobody
wants to come down with the virus
so we're skipping out on these and then
we have seen
unfortunately the huge disparity in the
minority communities when it comes to
health care overall
so talk about that disparity when it
comes to the black and brown communities
yeah so specifically in the
african-american community um we have to
recognize that there's a lot of
underlying conditions that are actually
more prevalent
um you know such as diabetes is 60
percent more common
and that increases the risk of heart
disease
and hypertension is actually the most
common risk factor especially for
african-americans
well you know 42 percent of black men
and 45 percent of black women have high
blood pressure
and they might not even realize it um
and african-americans are 5.6 times more
likely to get kidney disease and kidney
disease is another comorbid condition
that can cause you to have
more complications yeah so it is
definitely more difficult to see your
doctor
during um covet and you know you really
want to be
aware of you know being in a crowded
office room etc
yeah um so there's a couple ways around
that you know you can have telehealth
visits with your physician
um you can even have regular phone
checkups with your physician
um or even do things at home um you know
such as checking your
sugar regularly keeping a log of that uh
checking your blood pressure regularly
you know keeping track of that and that
way if you start to see that the numbers
are creeping up yeah
you know you can even just get a phone
consultation or
just talk to your doctor absolutely via
telehealth okay doc
let's talk about this i just want to
jump in here because i i have some some
questions for you that i really want to
get in before we wrap up what can women
do on a daily basis
dr nerala to to improve their overall
heart health because there are little
things that we can do to change these
statistics
yeah it's very simple um along with the
things i talked about checking your
blood sugar checking your sugar
um uh quit smoking uh if you're smoking
you know one out of six
one out of six americans are still
smoking um checking your blood
cholesterol
um and you know exercising that's a you
know very simple thing you can do
gyms are closed but you know i tell a
lot of my patients open your front door
put on some sneakers walk 15 minutes
turn around walk 15 minutes back
that's 30 minutes a day of getting
exercise and
you know to get moderate exercise such
as fast walking you need about 150
minutes a week
so 30 minutes a day five times a week
that should be good and you're good to
go
manage stress levels and make sure
you're sleeping well
yeah and doctor this is the final
question because we're almost out of
time here what about yearly testing at
what age should women
black or white start getting those
yearly checkups i started at 40 but
you're the expert tell our viewers
what they need to do so at age 20
is when the american college of
cardiology recommends getting a what's
called a lifetime risk
and that involves talking to your doctor
and estimating
you know am i at a higher risk panel am
i in the high risk category for this
disease and that
way you can start at 20. now if you
happen to follow
if you happen to fall in a lower risk
category that can be pushed to 40. and
at 40 when you start it or when other
people
start is when you start estimating the
10-year risk so
at that point you know things may change
between 20 and 40 and it's important
definitely by the age of 40 to get
screened absolutely okay doc i'm out of
time tell everybody where they can
contact
you if they have more questions so we're
part of desert cardiology and vascular
center we're in henderson nevada
you can visit our website
desertcardioenv.com
and we're on the corner of saint rosen
eastern all right so nice to finally see
you i like i said i've been going to
your dad for a while
so maybe the next time when i finally
come in for my checkup for 2021
i'll get a chance to meet you in person
thank you so much we appreciate it
it's it's nice to see you too annika
thank you very much all right
and ladies uh please jump on it because
i am currently taking
heart medication yes i am just being
really honest with you it
it takes a lot to maintain your health
and i hope that this kind of helped you
guys out i